next up we have
uh max ganes his talk today is on fusing
economic survey data sets with the since
impute python package
max is founder and president of the ubi
center
it's a think tank that researches
universal basic income policies
previously max worked at google as a
data scientist
he earned his ba in operations research
from uc berkeley and an ms in data
economics and development policy from
mit
max we're we're pleased to have you join
us today and i will
make you co-host and and um
please start your presentation
thanks so much for the intro and great
to be here at pi data um it's my second
time here but last year was a bit
different it was
uh so it's good to actually have a live
audience now
um
yeah as jennifer mentioned i am founder
and president of the ubi center where a
think tank that researches
universal basic income policies um and
i'm actually
also we started a new kind of spun off a
new tech non-profit called policy engine
and uh that's really what i'm on
or i'm here on behalf of today
so i will share my screen
yeah so what we do at policy engine our
mission is to make everyone a policy
maker
and we do that by producing a single
unified product that lets anyone reform
the tax and benefit system and see the
impact both on society and their own
household
to do this we have to apply
pretty complicated economic micro
simulation modeling and synthetpu is a
python package that we've developed to
make that more
robust so i thought i'd do is
give a little bit of a more more
background on policy engine and a quick
demo of our product
and demonstrate why economic policy
analysis relies on data fusion talk
about some of the existing approaches to
that and some comparisons of that and
also then um of course how to synthemp
works itself and what's coming next
so sort of what motivates us here is
that taxes and benefits are just an
enormous part of the economy so about a
third of gdp is collected as taxes among
developed countries today and that's up
from about about a quarter back in 1960
um
and the third of that third is spent on
cash benefits so this could be pensions
child benefits uh welfare programs
and both these numbers are
moving upward and
if there's just not really great
analysis tools for understanding how
those
programs work
so even if you're in government or a top
top think tank or
advisor to a policy maker
you pretty much have to rely on these
kinds of programs so in the eu and the
uk there's
kind of these semi closed access windows
applications
and very difficult to use not intuitive
a lot of think tanks have their own
closed applications
so it's really just
behind the scenes to power their own
reports and they're closed source
in the u.s if you want to figure out
just are you eligible for benefit
programs like food stamps maybe your
state has a estimator that'll tell you
if you're eligible or not but in many
cases um you don't even get that and if
it's just eligible you don't know what
other benefits are you eligible for or
how much do you actually get
i've been pretty involved in some tax
micro simulation tools so we have a
there's a tool called tax brain which is
built by the policy simulation library
and that's open source and i think does
a really good job but it's really uh it
doesn't cover the benefit side
so in most cases if there's a policy
change that's being discussed there's
just no tooling at all to and now to
understand that
so my co-founder nikhil woodruff and i
we come at this from
both the tech and the science and
policy analysis background so
we both have contributed to open source
models in the us and the uk
and we kind of met through working at
the ubi center which is a think tank
that i founded and then we as we started
building this
essentially a front end for micro
simulation technology we realized it
actually had
more um potential than just for our
think tank by itself so we're making
available typhoon which it was before
but it's kind of
in a different vein now
so for apple i'll go through in a second
it's a mobile-friendly web app that lets
anyone design
benefit or tax reforms we also have an
api so folks who are interested in
developing
tools that might make use of both what
people are eligible for in terms
benefits what's their current tax
liability or how those kinds of metrics
will change under uh policy reforms they
can use our api as well
and 100 of our work is open source where
the we actually developed the first
open source micro simulation model in
the uk
and we're the only tool that um
that provides this kind of front end for
the tax and benefit side completely open
source so we're all all on github
all right with that i'll jump to policy
engine uk so we're live in the uk we're
currently building the us product
and um
here is kind of how policy engine looks
today we hope to make it a little bit
simpler in the future but you go onto
the site and you see a whole bunch of
policy parameters that you can change
so we've got our tax system here um
national insurance is kind of like
payroll taxes for those in the u.s
and then a whole bunch of benefit
programs so
universal credit is actually the biggest
one or main mean sets of program state
pensions also um very very large
and uh we also have some sort of user
contributed
sections which we'll get into in a bit
so actually just wednesday in the uk
there was a reform to the universal
credit system which was announced so
this
we can start with this and actually see
a real world example here
so we've got a whole bunch of stuff we
can actually just repeal the whole
program if we want to or we can change
the amounts that people get um
we can also abolish different elements
of it but the thing that actually
changed in the reform was this work
allowance so this is the amount that you
can
earn before you start losing your
benefit so this was raised by 500
pounds per year which is 42 per month so
that's going to be 557
here
and plus 42 is going to be 335.
the phase out rate was also reduced from
63 to 55
so now we've got our policy we can sort
of see the plan up here
and now we can see the impact on the uk
all right so we see that this reform
would cost 2.7 billion it would reduce
poverty by 2 and 12 of people would
benefit um this is a pure additional
spending program so no nobody comes out
behind
and we can also see the poverty impact
by age so child poverty falls 4.3
percent
um
you can see that actually the third
decile benefits the most on a relative
basis and also in terms of the share of
people who come out ahead so those in
the third decile about one in four of
those come out ahead compared to
just you know one in 20 125 in the
bottom decile
and then the last thing is you can also
describe your household so let's say
we're a married couple with a couple
kids
you can actually change your employment
income let's go to
around 24 k see what happens there
and we can see okay this reform is going
to
uh pretty significantly affect the
household finances for this
person this household
about six percent increase
and we can also see if they earned more
or less they might be trying to decide
how you uh should i
get a raise or what happens if i get a
raise or what happens if i work more or
less
so we can zoom in on the area where the
reform changes from the baseline and we
see from roughly
you know uh
6 000 employment income to about
35 000 employment income they are going
to come out ahead and this all is
customized based on the parameters that
they entered
and finally we have the marginal tax
rate so um
because the benefit program currently
faces at 63
that's a marginal tax rate that is added
on top of the actual tax rate so
currently people pay about 75 marginal
tax rates if they're sort of in the
highest area
and this reform would kind of smoothen
that out so
it would only rise to about 69 percent
because
the phase out rate falls
so that's basically the motivation for
what we're doing here
i think i'll
talk now about what
goes into models like these um
with micro simulation and data fusion
so the general idea behind the kind of
product that we work on policy engine
and similar products
is
you if you were trying to figure out
what is the impact on the poverty rate
or the budget or the share of people who
come ahead or behind
you apply a technique called micro
simulation
and this involves
getting a government survey that's
representative of the society
and each of these usually there's tens
of thousands of rows or so
you're going to have some information
about that household
such as earnings numbers of kids marital
status
maybe dividends capital gains other
kinds of income
and you then have a program that runs
through that for every household in the
survey
so here's a very simplified kind of view
of how this looks you've got
um 100k earnings this household has zero
kids so maybe they pay 30 000 in taxes
and their benefits
they've earned too much to get benefits
so their net income is going to be 70k
this help households pretty similar but
they have some kids so they're going to
get
a little bit more in benefits uh so 76k
net income
and then this household is going to
actually per child get more um benefits
they might also get benefits because
they're just a low income adult so their
net income is going to be 30k
so you kind of do this for every
household in the survey
um usually the households have different
weights so they represent different
number of people in the sur in the
population
so you're going to take a weighted sum
of all these numbers like tax
liabilities benefits and that's how you
get the
total impact on society
so that's pretty simple if it's all in
one survey all the data you need
but let's say you want to combine
multiple surveys so for example let's
say there's a wealth tax that's being
discussed
well
you don't have wealth in the main survey
data set you've used to calculate tax
and net income
but there's a separate survey
that has both earnings and wealth so in
the u.s this is pretty concretely this
might be on the left side the current
population survey and on the right side
might be the survey of consumer finances
um
and
this doesn't have all the information
that you need to calculate all the other
taxes and benefits but it does have this
wealth variable
so the question is how do you use this
data to estimate wealth in this data set
and there are a number of approaches
that you could you can use
i think the key insight that we've
found in synth compute is you actually
want to predict the conditional
distribution you don't want to just
predict a single number for each one of
those
and that's because when you're computing
taxes and benefits you have to know the
full
distribution of
values that it could take because
there's a very progressive in many
societies there's a progressive system
so there's going to be a big difference
between
saying three households have an average
of 10 million in wealth each
compared if you say okay three each of
them has 10 million compared to one has
30 million one has zero million well
if your
first 10 million is exempt from the
wealth tax
those are going to produce entirely
different tax revenue numbers
so that's why here we're basically
saying we want not just this is the what
we might call the point estimate of
wealth we want actually the full
distribution of wealth based on earnings
number of kids that come from this data
set
and uh then we're maybe going to pick a
random value from within that predicted
um distribution
all right so what this general problem
is is
uh quantile regression is kind of a
general approach to figuring out the
conditional distribution
and a couple examples of tools that can
be used for this
so here's a
very simple example just you're trying
to predict one variable from one other
variable
ordinary least squares linear regression
is going to have parallel lines so you
basically take your
regression coefficient and then you have
a standard error around that so you can
use that to estimate quantiles depending
on the other covariates
and these are always going to be
parallel
if you want to get a little more
complicated you can use quantile
regression where the slopes can differ
but they're still always going to be
straight lines
if you want to get more
complicated still you can use
non-parametric methods like random
forests which
didn't do very well i think random
forests need a few more variables to
perform well
or tensorflow so this is a deep learning
kind of approach where you're going to
essentially identify different kinks in
the data but still going to be straight
lines otherwise
so we did to figure out what approach we
should use when we're
doing this for policy engineering
products
is use a real world data set so
in this case we have a survey of
consumer finances we're going to try to
predict the quantiles of wealth and like
any other
kind of machine learning
system you want to have some way to
predict on new data
and see how it performs here so we did a
pretty simple 20 hold out we could
probably get similar results from other
um kinds of
approaches
and we tried to predict wealth quantiles
based on 11 features
so these features were things like where
the income the age family size marital
status and different types of earnings
as well
and we predicted a few different
quantiles
so seven different quantiles are what
we're predicting and we do that with a
few different
methods so
um i didn't show it here but one of the
most common approaches for this problem
is um essentially matching
so if we go back to
this table here we might just say okay
what's the most similar looking record
in um this table and that table so we're
going to say okay 100k
zero kids i guess the most similar is
going to be this 120k
and you can do this
statistically of course
um
and automatically but that's going to
give you 900k where 25k maybe just grab
the 22k
so
um
yeah that's a very common approach
so we tried that we tried ols we tried
quantile regression and also tensorflow
and random force
and we evaluated with quantile loss
so what is quantile loss this is kind of
the key part of quantile regression um
quanta loss actually looks very similar
to something you may have
seen before if you're predicting the
median so
at the 50th percentile it's really just
mean absolute error divide by two
so 50th percentile if you're either
ahead or behind your error is positive
or negative it's fully symmetric
um
so this compares pretty similarly to
mean squared error which
is a very common loss function for
for example ols
it gets a little more interesting if
you're predicting percentiles that are
not 50
so for example if you're trying to
predict the 90th percentile the point at
which 90 of the observations would fall
below that
you're actually going to penalize
um errors that are too low
more
than errors are too high
and vice versa for
uh
low quantiles you're gonna predict
uh penalize low errors less for low
quantiles
so the idea is you have to
have different quantile losses for every
quantile you're assessing
all right so what did we find well turns
out random force actually did the best
uh by
quite a bit compared to the status quo
of matching and this kind of makes sense
because matching doesn't actually
predict
a conditional distribution it predicts a
single value
um so ols did better the matching
quantile regression did better still
tensorflow and random force were pretty
similar
it turns out random forest is actually a
lot easier to use because you can
have just one single model if you're
familiar with random forests it has a
bunch of different predicted values
which usually are just used to figure
out what the average is but you can just
use that to have an empirical
cumulative predicted distribution so you
don't have to do separate
models as tensorflow sort of does for
every specific quantum
so yeah random force did really well if
you also decompose this by each quantile
random force did better than all the
others on almost all of the quantiles
except the very top ones so
tensorflow did a bit better at
predicting the top but um
random forest was still
pretty
um
pretty competitive in that area and it
did better at the other quantiles
i will say i think we could definitely
do better with tensorflow if we put more
research into tuning it but as i said
random forces just
ends up a lot easier to use
all right so this is what
led to our decision to use synth compute
and synthempu really just has
one core function that is used uh rfmp
so this imputes data with random force
what it does is it takes a few
um arguments but these are the three
most
uh important ones
and these are very similar to
what other prediction
apis look like so you've got
your training data set on the y you've
got your training
[Music]
sorry training data set as x-train and
your training labels
and also your new variables for x
so what this does is it calculates a
conditional distribution for every
record in x new
and it's going to select a random
quantile within that distribution
so this is going to ensure
that you're going to get
a proper overall distribution
both on the app
aggregate level and also for individual
um
you know similar kind of records and we
actually have an option as well where
you can
have
replicates of the x new and it's going
to predict uh
multiple times
so you get the full distribution there
we also do something that um
goes beyond the standard rf compute
approach where you still you enter also
your target
overall
value that you want it to sum to
so what this does is instead of
selecting a random quantile it's going
to select a semi-random
quantile and this basically means it's
going to select from some variable value
from the beta distribution rather than a
uniform when it's predicting which
quantile to select
and it then optimizes this to say
what um
[Music]
what were we going to do in terms of the
average
quantile to hit that target
so one example is food stamps are known
to be under-reported in survey data so
let's say we know that food stamps have
80 billion dollars that are spent on
them every year but the surveys only say
it's 50 billion well if you're trying to
impute data from
from that under reported value to make
sure that it's 80 billion
there's still you you could just
multiply by either over five
but
there are real values that are
in the survey data that are more common
than others and that represents a real
um systemic feature of the program so
instead if you say i'm not going to just
select so that the average quantile is
0.5 which is what the uniform
description does i'm going to select so
the average quantile is 0.6 or 0.7
that
adjusting that number is going to get
you closer to hitting that 80 billion so
that's what rfmp allows as well
max we've had a question from lewis
he asks
did you try tensorflow probability to
check the distribution of results
no um we actually developed this before
tensorflow probability was introduced so
yeah i'd love to try that actually
um thanks for the suggestion
all right i think almost done here just
want to share a bit about where we're
headed um
so one of the things i
i think i
showed it here maybe if we go back to
policy engine
um we've we have this live in the
product in one place and that's land
value tax
so you can actually select
a different value for uh tax on the
value of land
and that's going to show up in the uk
impact and
those pages
so we do that by taking
our core household survey which is
um we're sorry the survey that has land
value which is the wealth and asset
survey
so we can estimate land value there it
also has some other
variables that let's match it to the
family resources survey which is the
core household data set we use in
policy engine uk
so we use some compute to to do that we
also use the the feature that i
described of um
setting a target
so we want to do this for
a lot more surveys for example the
household surveys usually don't have
data on wealth
land of course carbon emissions
consumption so we can grab from these
asset surveys and these are going to
differ by country
but we can grab it for wealth we can
grab
we can basically calculate carbon
emissions in the consumption survey and
then if we want to do a carbon tax
simulation we can do that in the
household survey as well
same with the consumption tax like a vat
we can also use administrative records
to improve the income in the survey so
for example the current population
survey in the u.s
um the income is actually top coated so
if you have
tens
of millions of dollars in income it's
only going to cap that at uh maybe one
million so we're
so we can use tax data to improve that
estimation
all right and you know where does this
go ultimately in terms of the product
experience well policy engine we want to
build an app
that is one vision where we have a much
more democratic participatory approach
to policy making where you open your app
and you kind of see
from policy makers like political
parties or think tanks or individuals
policy ideas that everyone has and we're
all having the same data oriented
personalized conversation around how
those policies affect both you as an
individual as well as society
and you can click in to see the all the
details i went through before
click into profiles to see what kind of
pro
policies individuals have put forth
but all this sort of unified and
enhanced by having more accurate more
robust data underlying it
so that's all i have if happy to take
any questions and yeah you can go to
policyengine.org if you'd like to try it
out we're at the policy engine
on twitter
and uh my email is max policy engine.org
great well um
thank you so much for the the
presentation today max
thank you very much it's great to be
here